et voilà le dernier bronze est installé
priver de salon à cause du confinement
la sculptrice un oiseau vert a trouvé la
solution puisqu'elle ne peut pas montrer
ses oeuvres dans des expositions
elle propose au public de venir voir si
sculpture chez elle dans cette pièce
qu'elle a transformé en galerie
c'est effectivement très important de
pouvoir et montrer son art et pouvoir le
partager puisque bien évidemment ces
sculptures sont en vente
et si l'on travaille et donc
c'est vraiment indispensable de montrer
son art mais rien ne vaut quand même une
visite à l'atelier à la galerie pour
pouvoir apprécier des sculptures sous
tous les angles
et puis il est touché les voir des yeux
enfin et il y apprécier l'art de visu en
fait
la sculptrice est montré son travail
elle peut parler pendant des heures des
corps et des visages quel modèle pour
faire ressortir émotions et sentiments
durant le confinement l'artiste a
continué de créer inspiré par le
compositeur beethoven né il ya 250 ans
je peux dire que beethoven à sauver -
d'années parce que depuis depuis janvier
je travaille sur
avec lui j'ai la musique chez sa
neuvième symphonie quasiment boucle et
je suis vraiment porté images je veux
dire c'est ça a été une année quand même
très créative et grâce à lui merci mes
tomates
[Musique]
si vous voulez découvrir le travail de
noise aubert prenez rendez vous elle
vous accueille jusqu'au 20 décembre
[Musique]